riot games is paying out 100 million
dollars in a settlement to women who
experience sexual harassment and
discrimination while working for the
company now that sounds like a lot of
money and it is but the story is a
little bit more complicated than riot
just finally doing something decent when
it comes to this whole situation
let's talk about it
so on december 27th the washington post
shannon liao reported that riot games
the california department of fare
employment and housing the california
division of labor standards enforcement
and quote certain claimants had reached
a 100 million dollar settlement about a
2018 lawsuit regarding gender
discrimination that took place at the
company in plain english riot is paying
out 100 million dollars to women who
experience sexual harassment and
discrimination while working at riot
games this is obviously a big deal but
there's a lot of context that we have to
lay out before we talk about what this
means and what happens next starting at
the very beginning in august 2018 kotaku
published a report by cecilia donastasia
alleging that there was a culture of
sexist attitude and gender
discrimination at riot games the article
included quotes from then current and
former ride employees about how women
were often paid less than a minute riot
given less raises than men at riot and
were given fewer promotions than men at
riot a few months later in november 2018
then current ride employees just negron
and melanie mccracken filed a lawsuit
alleging that there was gender
discrimination and sexual harassment
occurring at riot games and were seeking
damages this was followed a few months
later by riot attempting to force women
into private arbitration which was
followed by employees walking out in
protest in may and the dfvh announcing
they were looking into riot in december
2019 wright agreed to pay 10 million
dollars to settle the lawsuit and
committed to improving company culture
but then the dfeh and dlsc stepped in to
say that they believe the women involved
in the class-action lawsuit actually
deserved 400 million dollars and blocked
ryan from paying out the 10 million they
did this according to court filings
because the dlsc stepped in to say that
they believed the lawyers representing
the women at ryan did not do their due
diligence and could have quote let right
off the hook for breaking more labor
laws which basically brings us up to
today after months of pretty much radio
silence riot is now paying out 100
million dollars to these women now that
is 10 times what they originally agreed
to pay but it's also a quarter of what
the california state agencies originally
said they should be paying 80 million
dollars is going directly to the women
suing riot while the other 20 million is
going to pay their legal fees in a
statement riot's executive team stated
that the reason they're paying out so
much more now is because there are more
parties involved there are more lawyers
which increases the legal fees but more
importantly the class suing riot has
grown a lot since the original lawsuit
was filed basically in a class action
lawsuit a group of people who were
wronged by another party are considered
a class and what started as a relatively
small class in this particular lawsuit
grew a lot since ryde agreed to pay the
10 million back in 2019. see now it
covers all people who identify as women
who worked full time or in temporary
contract positions at riot since
november 2014. basically riot is saying
one of the reasons they're paying out so
much more money is because there are a
lot more people suing them now now to be
clear a settlement like this is not an
admission of guilt we'll get to how riot
feels about what went down in a bit but
for now what you have to understand is
that this isn't right admitting that
they broke labor laws in fact in their
statement riot's executive team says
this given the ambitious goals we have
for camp 2 and the tens of millions of
dollars we'd spend each year on lawyers
to help resolve these cases money we'd
rather pay to the women in this class
and to invest in riot's future it became
clear during these past several months
that the best outcome for everyone would
be to come to a final resolution
effectively what riot is saying here is
that if they were gonna fight this in
court the legal fees were gonna balloon
like crazy so it'd be cheaper and better
honestly to just pay out money to the
women who are allegedly discriminated
against or sexually harassed while
working at riot this is a pretty common
reason for settlements by the way
somebody realizes that a protracted
court battle is going to be a lot
messier and a lot more expensive than
just paying out the money right now and
making the lawsuit go away and to be
clear just because i sound super cynical
about all this doesn't mean i think this
is terrible or something i think it's
genuinely great that riot has to pay out
10 times what they originally agreed and
that it seems like women are going to be
receiving repertory funds for the harm
they experience while working at riot
but riot is still referring to the
lawsuit as being around alleged gender
harassment and discrimination occurring
at the company while also saying this we
also know that at the end of the day
this issue isn't just about legal
arguments it's about human beings and
their individual experiences while we're
proud of how far we've come since 2018
it's important that we also take
responsibility for our past that began
with an apology to rioters because
despite our best intentions we haven't
always lived up to our values we
followed with significant upgrades to
our people in dni practices and now
today with a proposal for meaningful
repair remember a settlement isn't an
admission of guilt a court never found
that gender discrimination took place at
riot games and a court never found that
sexual harassment occurred at riot games
in the eyes of the law riot isn't guilty
of any of this which is why they're
using some really careful language in
this statement to avoid admitting that
they potentially broke the law however a
lot of people perceive settlements like
this as admissions of guilt in the court
of public opinion we're all free to
perceive whatever we want to but to be
clear riot isn't admitting anything all
they're saying is that some bad stuff
has happened at riot games offices over
the years and they feel really bad about
that a hundred million dollars bad
specifically anyway i brought all that
up to sort of highlight the big thing
for me here see riot is shelling out all
this money we're not gonna have a big
protracted court battle the women who
were hurt are getting money i think all
of that is good basically but what's
more nebulous is what happens next the
law firms representing the women suing
riot are quoted in the statement
basically saying it's a great day for
women in the games industry and that
hopefully this marks a trend moving
forward of women demanding fair
treatment of pay notably we've been
hearing stories about similar things
happening at other major game studios
like activision blizzard and ubisoft all
of this has happened and in some cases
might still be happening at some studios
but what are the next steps riot talks
in the statement about investing in the
future but what does that look like
riot's ceo nicola laurent is quoted in a
statement and he's currently embroiled
in a sexual misconduct lawsuit his
former executive assistant is suing him
for allegedly behaving improperly
towards her and while riot has cleared
him internally after a third party
investigation found that he didn't do
anything the lawsuit alleges sharon
o'donnell his former assistant has
doubled down on her claims scott gelb
who according to a separate kotaku
report by anastasio allegedly walked
around the office doing things like
grabbing people's balls humping
employees as a joke and farting on
people was suspended without pay back in
2018
but then in january 2021 he was promoted
to president of games at riot these are
two names that have been alleged of
fostering the kind of attitude at riot
that led to this lawsuit in the first
place i'm not going to say that progress
is impossible with folks like these two
at the helm because one these
allegations have not been proven in a
court of law so that's all they are
right now allegations but two i have to
believe that people can change and grow
otherwise we're all [ __ ] but you can't
deny that the optics here are a little
bit screwy riot talks a big game in the
statement about how far they've come
since 2018 and how they're gonna invest
in their future to make it a better
place to work meanwhile it takes about
five seconds of googling to see all the
horrible things their senior staff has
been accused of ultimately settlements
like this are often backed with ndas so
this story probably is over for now the
people suing riot will likely be asked
to sign papers guaranteeing their
silence about this issue in the future
that means that if riot is actually
doing the work and things are changing
internally we're probably not going to
hear anything no news is good news in
this case but if things don't change or
if they somehow get worse than what's
been reported then those ndas might
start getting broken or newer employees
will become the whistleblowers and at
that point it'll be pretty clear that
there's a real problem here
you